ça vous nous sommes dans les rues de
caen est ce que vous avez vu les gants
dilek et aux jets on est là où vous êtes
ici peu charrié alors
[Musique]
nouvel ep de candidats est sorti le 4
novembre
on vous a vu en pleine forme à
beauregard festival célèbre en 2016
est-ce que depuis vous avez fait
beaucoup de choses des dates qu'est ce
que vous avez fait noël alors on a pas
mal tourné depuis depuis borg enfin on a
repris les dates au mois de septembre
donc cet ep sorti de 4 novembre on a
enregistré en fait en février
donc ça nous a demandé beaucoup de
boulot en fait donc on a passé pas mal
de temps à le préparer
l'album a été enregistré chez nous en
normandie il est enregistré au studio du
hameau dans l'orne donc perdre dans le
perche mais si c'est moi au milieu un
peu de nulle part dans un superbe studio
ou quand on y va on y va vraiment
refaire que ce à quoi il ya aucun moyen
de le faire autre chose de ce d'être
comment dire à collectionner voilà donc
c'était super on a enregistré sa
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous a apporté la
participation à bord car justement une
libération quelques lapins ou pas du
tout nous ça nous a permis
c'était un bon dialogue parce que ça
nous a permis en fait de faire une
résidence aussi aux délais c'est donc
paul dangereux le directeur nous a
accueilli dans sa salle pour y
retravailler live et ça nous a bien bien
préparé en fait on a fait une résidence
début mais on est parti à londres on a
fait deux dates à londres dans la foulée
pour préparer en fait cela et fly on est
arrivé à beauregard plutôt bien d'un
très bon quoi c'est une belle expérience
de scène c'est la première fois qu'on
jouait devant le temps de monde
have fun
[Musique]
ps3
on
de l'air
là
alex comment vous avez rencontré arthur
pour tout dire c'était y'a pas très loin
d'ici
moi je n'ai jamais mes compos j'étais
toujours seul chez moi à les faire
j'avais envie de partager un peu ma
musique
il se fait qu'à quand on a l'opportunité
d'aller dans des endroits on peut
rencontrer les musiciens on se
connaissait de vue
bon j'ai mes compos je vais simplement
voir fredo voir arthur à ça vous dirait
qu'on qu'on essaye de voir de boeuf et
un peu voir ce que ça donne et c'est
parti comme ça en fait c'était super
simple à autour d un tournant picon
bière même je crois mais on va commencer
à me fais des trucs qu'on on a
complètement oublié depuis et alors là
on a fini par mac était en fait le
premier morceau qui était réservé les
singles faudra sortir en 2014
[Musique]
de plus
quand il a comporté mélo à caen le 15
décembre on retrouve patrick mars
pour du cirque
enfin presque là où ça bouge nous sommes
à yves devant le cirque borsberg où va
se tenir vendredi une soirée caritative
je suis avec karl le directeur le
monsieur loyal du cirque
c'est quoi cette soirée cette soirée en
fait c'est un petit peu l'idée du gala
de l'union des artistes qui se passe à
paris au cirque d'hiver où des comédiens
des personnalités du showbiz voilà font
font les artistes d'un soir pour la
bonne cause et donc j'ai souhaité
recréer un petit peu voilà accord avec
des sportifs des journalistes des gens
de la région
on va faire ce spectacle au bénéfice de
l'association léa à cette éternelle qui
en fait
aide les enfants qui sont atteints du
cancer également qui accompagnent leurs
familles aussi
voilà vous savez tout ce vendredi cet
inventeur c'est 10 euros 10 euros
l'entrée
tarif unique tarif unique et tous les
bénéfices seront reversés à
l'association
et ben voilà venez nombreux vous attend
les et gagnante c'est le nom du nouveau
festival de cinéma de 40 ans neuf films
sont au programme dont paul dans sa vie
de rémi mauger les et gagnante de
vendredi à dimanche
merci m'accuser donc à 40 ans et environ
avec aussi des ciné concerts comme
demain soir à 20h30 au théâtre de
carentan avec les gousses evans entre
autres et l'orchestré d'harmonie de 40
en présence aussi dans ce festival
le dominique besnehard et d'orelsan
[Musique]